everything I know about cooking I've
learned through hard work drive and
passion from the age of 17 I made food
my life and it's fair to say that since
then food has been the making of me but
the sort of cooking I made my name with
intricate dishes made with the world's
finest ingredients is a million miles
away from the food I grew up on
for the first program in the series I'm
updating some of the home-cooked dishes
I absolutely adored when I was a kid
first up for breakfast at Classic from
my childhood stunning baked beans with
fluffy potato cakes next a modern take
of my favorite childhood lunch fantastic
fish fingers and an irresistible chip
butter my mouth is salivating and I've
got competition in the kitchen as mum
helps make dinner
be doing this person because she's the
best to cook excuse me when I was a kid
this was my dream dinner super
comforting shepherd's pie with peas and
carrots followed by a steamed date
pudding with butterscotch sauce to die
for
let's get this shoe on the road come
this is my ultimate childhood breakfast
lunch and dinner
first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day easy homemade spicy baked
beans with deliciously light potato
cakes
[Music]
the first big thing that I remember as a
kid was bacon and beans so this is like
a little rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta Ernie come on disappear don't
chase the mice nah panel get nice and
hot I'm gonna turn these beans into
almost beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how an individual Taste of
baked beans they're somewhat Bland so I
always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so a nice finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a bit of garlic
crushed phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across
then cut down to Simply dice
bacon onion chili garlic
for that flavor all contained in that
little pan
once you sweat the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken and enrich as well at the same
time
that looks beautiful
now
a couple of tablespoons cider vinegar
deglaze the pan it's got that really
nice powerful kick to it now spice that
up
with one of my favorite Seasons
Worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
passata puree tomatoes
turn that down simmer the sauce to
reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harico beans
you can buy harika beans dried or canned
They are packed with protein and have a
lovely soft texture turn down the heat
and that the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
I'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of cakey
texture and it goes from this leftover
ball potato to this nice light
flowery
potato Heaven take a nice
spoon or potato lightly flour your board
we're going to fry these crisp
on the outside and just nice and fluffy
in the center now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown
gently
turn it over
love that nice light crisp they look
beautiful
now take them out
oh
potato cake in the middle
and a nice beautiful
spoon
of beans
growing up with beans on toast As a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans especially cooked like that
[Music]
my Smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes comfort
and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you more of
the food that made me the man I am
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
shop for to make my ultimate lunch and
dinner
starting with Pollock
I grew up on Whitefish like cod and
haddock but today I'm using Pollock
whitefish-like Pollock has a wonderful
sweet firm flaky flesh
Pollock's so versatile bake it batter it
cook it up in fish pie or even cut it
into strips for my fish fingers which
I'm cooking for lunch
[Music]
growing up I ate tons of lamb mince meat
it's generally from less expensive but
tasty Cuts Like neck and belly
you can use lamb mints in so many ways
in Middle Eastern koftas or mixed with
mint for a Twist on a traditional Burger
but as a kid I couldn't get enough of
shepherd's pie and I'm making an amazing
version for dinner
foreign
potatoes almost every day as a kid I
love them but remember it pays to use
them properly they come in three types
flowery waxy and all Rounders
for Mash fried or roasting flowery
potatoes like King Edwards are brilliant
but boiling or salads use waxy potatoes
like Charlotte
[Music]
if you want the best of both worlds in
your kitchen go for an all-rounder like
Desiree I'm using them to make
incredible Oven Chips next
when I was growing up food in Britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you could
even buy avocados in the shops where I
lived Paris kitchens might have been
cooking nouvelle Cuisine but it
certainly hadn't made any inroads around
our way my ultimate lunch when I was
growing up was very plain pretty trashy
but I still love it now and again fish
fingers with a delicious chip putty
Secret
of a good tip buddy
is in the potato
now these are Desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop I used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today I'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a Twist
simply peel
slice and Blanche for three to four
minutes
drain
season and cover well with Paprika
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that next up easy fish fingers
this is Pollock
a really nice firm delicious fish got
the fish and finger size battens of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish it firms the
fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little bit
more durable especially in the pan now
for the coating start by thoroughly
coating the fish in seasoned flour and
then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then it stops those Corners
almost burning in a pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is Dill goes brilliantly
well with a fish
and run the deal through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip putty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side
I want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders where the
breadcrumbs and the deal
nice and carefully
take them out
I mean look they smell incredible so
nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip buddy starting
with button thick crusty bread
[Music]
slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavor
on
slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on weathership buddy there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that I've never
forgotten the joy I've come for food but
my God that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for a moment
I want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers are my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
[Music]
when I was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed date pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now I'm gonna sieve the flour would you
I'll chop here shallow chop those dates
please it was a favorite wasn't it
amazing Sue it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't that
steamed
was so steam you had Jam roly-proly so
the zest of the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant sort of helps get that
richness of the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
such an easy recipe yes looks fantastic
on the table
and then treacle
in wow look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please thank you
little dude and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if I pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yeah
thank you
you see I always just think that it was
an old-fashioned dessert steamed pudding
do you ever remember me tumbling around
your knees trying to sort of get in
there yeah so you like to lick the ball
didn't you all the time yeah
lightly Grease the mold you're always
willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never change I think I was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
could still enjoy this tonight wouldn't
they yeah delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is keep that nice and
tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh I washed my hand
come on
tightly covered with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it Steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to worship God
just for once worship
oh dear goodness you let that smash mom
you handed it to me and he dropped it
come on whilst mum forces me to break
the habit of a lifetime dude that's the
thought of you washing up it does that
to you here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over medium Heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood in a
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie what's the
secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
I would think the vegetables you use and
brown in it so we're gonna use leeks and
onions and I'll start Browning off the
mint you know no color no flavor I've
never forgotten that you know that yep
so good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that gray tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks greasy and
cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and I know
you don't do cheaper nasty let me clear
your peelings now ah all right thank you
very much there's no Nails in there now
is there no no
I remember your
amazing shepherd's pie and that lovely
little restaurant used to work in in
sheep Street in Stratford Haven so you
never got food sent back
no long time has complained that there
wasn't enough come on no I'm tempted you
never ever got a complaint no
how long did you work at that restaurant
for six years six years
what are you cooking I'm gonna make okay
I saw the modern version of Nana's
shepherd's pie that shouldn't Manny be
doing the cooking because she's the best
to cook excuse me
our onion please Danny yeah oh gosh your
eyes are gonna water
um
in there we've got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding
[Music]
is
um how does skeletons call their friends
skeleton's cooler friends I'm not too
sure on this on this bone Tilly come on
okay so
they're in a race one is called one two
three and the other is called under
twice who won
I don't know it depends who's the
fastest cat one two three because Under
12 cap thanks
oh goodness tell us while you make a
nice cup of tea for Nanny
yeah
thank you Don bye so give that a little
fry off okay
nice
talk to these jokes they get worse gosh
she's only having a bit of fun what's
the sauce that's gonna give that a
really nice spicy seasoning
thank you oh that's hot you okay yeah
it's tomato puree
you could put tomato tomatoes in this if
you like you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
I'm just gonna put a little touch I know
you'll go crazy at this a little touch
of red wine
well because I'm going to make it nice
and Rich
okay reduce the red wine down yeah and
then start covering your mince
with your stock
now I'm gonna bring it up to the ball
okay and then get some fresh Rosemary
okay like a little taste yes
yes it's a little bit hot careful
well either way
sorry
oh God
all right as it Cooks the house the wine
and the alcohol disappear it'll be
delicious trust me now gone spring
onions we'll chop up and that's going to
go through the mashed potatoes that's
going to sit on top of that knife I like
that savory yeah delicious mince it's
laced with all that red wine nice so
Springers into there Please Mum
and I'm going to drain off the potatoes
hello hello
yeah so I'm gonna dry out those potatoes
and then mash them no oh can I mash them
all right would you
um Holly slice a little knob of butter
in there for Jack please
well you're a chef I was a cook
exactly that
not really you used to help me with me
as well
right you kids do no potatoes
These are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want them look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey what are you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mamina yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that Dad I just wanted a
fork it to get it nice and spiky so I
want that nice crispy topping and then
lightly grate that cheddar cheese on top
and that goes in the oven literally 20
minutes 180 minutes Jack can you open
the door please man
doesn't it even though you said you
didn't like it earlier okay
back in the day Mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it doesn't it and then the carrots
that's why I didn't put carrots in let's
put them on the side I see last shot
before serving pour that gorgeous
butterscotch sauce over the pudding
I'll take one at a time that smells
incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steamed date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
other family
so now this is your recipe
this is Nan's recipe but modernized Mom
how is that very nice but you can't
taste the wine no that's right so give
it a chance to cook out of Nanny is
amazing do you like it to us yeah man
you did a good job excuse me none of
these recipes revamped
I think we got a new chef and they're
getting no wonder you're so delicious
no cheers
[Music]
you still didn't do the washing up there
are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
I love cooking for mates but I never
made the mistake of doing complicated
formal food who wants to be stressed out
on the time off however I do have a
reputation to keep up so the food has
got to be good whether it's breakfast
brunch lunch or dinner here's my
ultimate food for friends
having people over for a bit of a late
breakfast or brunch at the weekend is a
brilliant way to catch up with friends
and this dish is always a winner
gorgeous griddle polenta with roasted
tomatoes and a creamy ghost curd can't
wait to dive in next at lunch to knock
the socks off your mates Sensational
salt baked sea bream with easy braised
leeks and my middle daughter Holly gets
her hands dirty in the kitchen as we
cook a super simple dinner
guaranteed to be a hit with all your
loved ones stunning roast chicken
stuffed with aromatic chickpeas
a beautiful big green salad and an
amazing chocolate and hazelnut meringue
Tower
really good nice to see Holly get her
hands dirty right I think we all agree
ah this is my ultimate food for friends
breakfast lunch and dinner
first as a estheticated late breakfast
or brunch dish to impress your mates
easy griddle polenta with delicious
roasted tomatoes and creamy ghost curd
now polenta to the Italians is what
mashed potato is to Britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water
it's a little touch of olive oil stops
it from becoming too sticky I love
polenta it's a cornmeal made from ground
dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then
whisk that out
as it Cooks out
it naturally thickens
you see the grains becoming almost into
one nice fine pureed
polenta to take the polenta to another
level flavor wise season with salt and
pepper a good knob of butter and
Parmesan the quite generous with the
parmesan because polenta can be quite
dull I like it quite rich and creamy
delicious
now mix that in
no a nice smooth shiny glossy plant you
can eat polenta two ways like this it's
a glorious fluffy Mash or set then
griddled which is what I'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and let it
set
next I'm roasting fine tomatoes to
really intensify the flavor
olive oil on the bottom of the tray and
drizzle extra virgin olive oil on top
nip your tomatoes with your scissors if
you didn't burst them before they went
in the oven they'll explode so
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic
says the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going to take on all this lovely garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful age balsamic vinegar
and then
some time don't pick the time just trim
it like you're having a little haircut
nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle
should just fall out beautiful blend is
a nice garnish for grilled Meats it's
great when you're planning a big dinner
party the Plenty can be done one or two
days before a nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that Grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn all that nice sort of marking
and Char on the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now tomatoes
no
you've got these beautiful Vine tomatoes
that have been roasted and all that
wonderful flavor
now get your little tomatoes and just
sit them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that age basement vinegar and then a
little basil
I can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastically entertaining
in the morning set your plan to the
night before and you can have this
casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love
[Music]
coming up I've got some great lunch and
dinner recipes when you're cooking for a
crowd
[Music]
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
impress your friends
[Music]
keep your guests sweet here's some of
the most common sugars and what they're
best for
almost sticky muscovado sugar rich and
trickly in flavor it's great in biscuits
fruit cakes and pickles
powdery icing sugar dissolves without
heat making it perfect for butter creams
and icing
palm sugar made from the palm tree sap
is generally sold as a paste and brings
caramely flavors to Sweet and Savory
dishes
the secret to the meringue I'm serving
my mates for dinner is caster sugar part
way between granulated and icing sugar
in size it dissolves well it's the
ultimate sugar for baking
for the main course I'm using corn-fed
chicken you can buy them everywhere
they're great value they have a lovely
color and a rich flavor and with an
incredible stuffing roast chickens
guaranteed to be a crowd pleaser
sea bream and I think the Kilt head
variety with its disco Diva gold flash
is the most flavoursome
to check it's fresh its eyes should be
bright gills red and scales shiny
bream's great poached grilled or pan
fried but I'm going to bake it in a salt
crust for my ultimate lunch for friends
when I'm cooking lunch for a crowd on my
friends my policy is to keep it simple
and think big so instead of making lots
of little things I usually cook a whole
fish or a large joint of delicious meat
that way there's always plenty to go
around now you can have this prepared
and in the oven before any of your
guests arrive it looks super impressive
especially when you bring it to the
table this is my ultimate lunch for
friends
salt crusted Sebring served with braised
leeks and hazelnuts
first job is that salt crust this dish
looks intimidating but it is actually
very straightforward and very easy make
sure the guts are out and the fish is
clean the most important thing is always
leaving the skin and the scales on that
skin protects the actual flesh from
becoming salted give the fish a really
nice seasoning
inside even though we're putting a salt
crust on the outside it's still very
important to season the middle fennel
seeds
goes brilliantly well with Fish And then
slice the lemon nice large thick slices
the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish
fall over the fish and just squeeze the
juice now for the salt
about 150 ml to 200 mL of water what
you're trying to do now is bring the
salt together and you want to sort of
end up with a bowl of salt that looks
almost like snow
you'll need about two kilos of salt for
this and it doesn't need to be the fancy
stuff even though you're using a lot of
it it won't make the fish salty instead
the crust forms a kiln that retains
moisture
well basically
a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt get your
salt
and just start packing you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
Salmon or flatfish like soul but it's
not great with oily fish
now it looks like a ridiculous amount of
salt but it's really important to cover
all the fish
because you want that nice shell and the
minute salt hits the oven it sort of
tightens up and forms this
large crust that goes in at 180 degrees
for 25 to 30 minutes
whilst the fish Cooks is onto my
beautiful braised leeks
splash of olive oil leak is a very sort
of firm robust vegetable so it can take
a really nice Sear
the most exciting about these leagues I
either go Goose Creek or deceiving but
braised leaks colored properly with a
lot of flavor on there tastes absolutely
delicious
take a couple of cloves of garlic and
just crush them in with the leeks some
fresh thyme
get some butter in there
braising them in butter and white wine
gives them the most amazing flavor
braising as a chefy term for searing at
a high temperature then cooking with a
bit of liquid
bringing that up to the boil
and then
the rest of your butter
now
as the white wine reduces down the
flavor the leeks intensifying they glaze
turn it down just leave that little Gap
there if we totally
covered it then you're gonna get all
that condensation underneath the lid and
it'll just make the legs watery
the leaks will take about 12 minutes to
cook so now for the garnish roasted
hazelnuts they'll be roast in the oven
very bristle very firm so get them
inside pestle and mortar bit of
seasoning and just crush your nuts don't
over pound them I just want this nice
sort of rustic chopped toasted hazelnuts
now
get your knife you want that going
through with ease and turn off the gas
right absolutely adore them
like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy
now baste the leeks with the remaining
butter
spread your fat leaf parsley over
generously
and then just sprinkle
of toasted hazelnuts the combination of
that earthiness from the leeks the
roasted flavor from the hazelnuts that
is a stunning way of eating leeks
and now for the fish
and look now you just gently tap
top
and it starts falling away you can just
see
a peaceful
shine carefully lift off
so now peel that skin look how juicy and
succulent that seabream is stays
incredibly moist
the other great thing about cooking
whole fish like this it makes it so easy
to fill it
take your spoon run that down
through the top
the fish will just slide off
yeah
now
just
push back that lovely fillet and look
at that
is cooked beautifully and that's what
keeps them coming back for more
and more and more when you have friends
over you want to keep lunch relaxed lay
back but impressive and a salt crust
brain with beautiful braised leeks is
just that
one of the things I've learned about
running successful restaurants over the
past 20 odd years is it's not just the
food that keeps people coming back you
need to create a great atmosphere too
and it's the same at home
My ultimate dinner for friends is
utterly delicious but it keeps things
simple and easy in the kitchen
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen proving
this dinner's Child's Play to make is
middle daughter Holly
first shop get the chicken stuffed and
roasting now we all know
you love chicken I do
but we're gonna do it the way that Daddy
used to eat it in Paris okay now I'm
gonna hold that up okay season inside
please why is it yellow because it's a
comfort chicken obviously eats corn and
if you eat lots of corn yellow turn
yellow now what are those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah have a little
taste
first yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please now
chilies
can you hear that noise is that me
seeds have come out
the tops
I'm gonna add the chilies to chickpeas
in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest I love my zest
the absolutely right and that will plug
a volleyball
come on house don't worry about your
nails now come on baby you can do it
now time you pick off all those
wonderful little buds
see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that tar again
hmm slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little
bit and a CD yeah so imagine that flavor
going into the chicken that's going to
be delicious now nice soft butter in
with a Target
is that lovely yeah now I want you
gently to put your fingers through there
and just so we can get that butter under
there but I need those small beautiful
little hands
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done I want you
get a nice handful of butter
oh
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah butter running down and the breasts
stay nice and moist and like you
yeah all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic should I wash my
hands no not yet
we're gonna lay the garlic
onto the tray now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper make your skin nice and crispy
and then I'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that'll stop the butter from
burning and look at that
please open the door thank you everybody
and she goes
beautiful good job
thank you really good nice to see Holly
get our hands dirty right I think we all
agree huh
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue Tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and
whisk
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy Peaks
gently folding ground and chopped
hazelnuts
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
topping meringues with more finely
chopped hazelnuts
bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your Tower with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
[Music]
the chickens in the oven and the
desserts sorted now for a big easy green
salad
so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
a nice little squeeze of honey
honey yes and it will Splash
oh
aged
and this is your favorite this one isn't
it I just like the it has a nice
sweetness but then it has a better Nest
to it too nice
at least a virgin olive oil why do we
have to use a whisk not just a spoon the
purpose of using the Whisk is so it can
emulsify that more importantly you're
bringing all the ingredients together
taste
it's so yummy that is delicious
isn't it
a tip to loosen any vinaigrette and give
it a lighter taste is to add a spot of
water now the juice
of a Lemon Squeeze the lemon in
nice now we need some butter lettuce
start placing the salad around the
outside this one is a lullo Rosso
okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're sort of making a nice flower and
you put your heart in there
that's exactly what I'm trying to do a
nice beautiful flower
now
from there
crisscross your avocado what does
criss-crossing do instead of just slice
it again I'll show you now you put your
spoon in there and look that's so cool
all these nice little bits I want you to
sprinkle those little bits in here
I'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend is going to be
extraordinary yeah that romantic dinner
the roast chicken the beautiful salad
okay yeah so where your father taught
you
and how nice will that be all three of
us sat down eating at the same time very
nice
[Music]
all of you
all of you and I'd grab the chicken okay
now
look at this beauty
amazing doesn't it right so a little bit
what drizzle it
drip nice what I'm gonna do now squeeze
all that garlic and see how soft and
beautiful it is it smells amazing the
lemon that we stuffed inside the chicken
roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through
look at that nice
garlic puree into all my
chickpeas
in there from there
some of your vinegar
and
[Music]
now you crush them
because they're still nice hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree they're rich
delicious creamy vinaigrette the
chillies
I can guarantee you young lady but they
are the best
the finest the most delicious chickpeas
you've ever tasted
[Music]
go on then see
yeah right
and
now it will drizzle
thanks a virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on chickpeas and that is a roast chicken
Fit For A King going this looks really
yummy
how many pasta salad out please an
alcohol chicken whole roast chicken
stuffed with chickpeas serve with a big
green salad it's always a winner with
your buddies workmates or family
chickpeas are really really rich
stuffing is amazing I love chickpeas
because I like cheese from chicks
your first chicken recipe for you and
your boyfriend there are loads more
great home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the App
Store good luck
[Music]